love he was my life outside of work
everything he said was just so sweet I
just want to hug him and have him hold
me like I just want to hug him so bad
every single day he was saying something
that would touch my
[Music]
heart I was like a fish that hook was so
far down in my belly he's an evil
bastard he is such an evil
bastard I sold jewelry I sold
Investments I gave him $2.8
million romance scamming a global crime
wave that surged during our loneliest
months of the pandemic wiping out more
than $300 million from American bank
accounts in 2020 hello babies can have
is to find out where some of that money
went we'll track down these tenacious
Sweet Talkers Halfway Around the Globe
how much money has Michael sent you so
far more than 10K more than $10,000 and
learn how they've perfected their
Insidious one to punch before taking
your
money Z Steal Your
Heart it's so part
of and sometimes love
heads
[Music]
so we right right right right right yep
okay Sun drenched
Florida with all its wealth and retirees
it's what you might call a Target Rich
environment for romance
scammers
okay if you want to put on your glasses
just in case oh we
ready camera
speed okay we
rolling I've never been married but I've
dated and I just kind of felt like I
wanted to finally meet somebody after
Lou
died I I couldn't sleep well you know
after a divorce you're feeling very
lonely I thought you know if I'm going
to try marriage I better get going
because I'm 68 years old so I signed up
on Facebook dating and a half hour after
I signed up um I met Damian he says he
lives just the next city over he's an
orthopedic surgeon and we're the same
age he tells Susan he's on a 4-month un
peacekeeping mission in Yemen from his
photos he's fit and slightly graying
he's very handsome he's very flirty I
thought okay I can flirt this is fun he
tells me I'm really extremely grateful
for having you in my life spending time
with me drowns out all of the other
concerns and lights of my life oh wow
let's see is this your Journal that you
kept all the conversations you had I
wrote everything down so you were
keeping a journal of what you thought
was possible relationship that you're
going to have with this right my heart
really was overtaking my brain
completely um I thought about him
constantly every time the little ding
ding on Google Hangouts grab my
phone when Eric and I started writing it
filled up that hole he listened to me it
was a great healing thing for me he was
just so romantic he'd write me love
poems every single day he was feeling
that void in my
heart that was my broken heart he is
completely and totally crazy about me
and wants to be with me every single day
it's like who doesn't want that but only
2 weeks later she senses trouble I wake
up Monday morning and there's no videos
no quotes there's nothing so I sent him
a message I don't know why I haven't
heard from you you I hope you're okay
and I have been stressing now the entire
day is he alive is he dead I I don't
know the following morning Susan finally
gets a message that begins with six
crying emojis he said to me we were
under attack there were guys that came
into the compound uh one guy was shot I
really want to get out of this place I'm
scared for my life he then tells tells
me some of his colleagues paid their
contract off and he said I can pay him
$30,000 and I can then go
home you know you and I are a couple
were in this together he said I thought
if maybe you could pay half he goes that
would be
great it's so embarrassing that it was
close to 300 $1,000
$1,876 $2.8
million more than 6,400 Americans say
they were scammed after visiting dating
websites the rise of romance scams and
our increasing ease with online dating
go handin hand more than 44 million
Americans went on dating sites last year
giving scammers plenty to work
[Music]
with but victims are also being targeted
on social media a 69-year-old Sarasota
woman will soon lose her house after
falling victim to an online dating scam
the median loss of a victim in 2020 was
$2,500 but for victims 70 and older it
was nearly 10
grand with arrests rare and recovering
money practically unheard of romance
scammers operate with near
impunity but every so often there's a
high-profile butt
that provides a window into this murky
underworld earlier this year in a case
that's still pending US law enforcement
charged six alleged ring leaders of a
massive cyber criminal Enterprise that
included romance scaming based in the
West African
country of
Ghana
Ghana is booming its economy is one of
the fastest growing in the world big
name companies like Google and Twitter
are planting headquarters here to take
advantage of an English-speaking
population that's young techy and
ambitious but those same traits have
also made Ghana a hot bed for romance
scammers that's why I've come to rack
them down and to understand how they've
turned online seduction into a thriving
criminal
industry one that's even made its way
into the country's music
scene
okay what was the music video you're
shooting here what is it about oh it's a
story about a lady who is very beautiful
that uh kind of like uses her appearance
to real people online meet boss bouncy
The Man Behind the song Ghana scammer
she make you fall too deep in love and
kind of like dup you and then take up
your money so she's a gold digger and a
scammer yeah yeah it's not good is
scamming big in Ghana oh I think it's
been in the news it's been on the radio
it's been on online so yeah so would you
be able to you think introduce us to
some people that you know or is that not
something you feel comfortable with no I
don't think people will really feel
comfortable telling you they know
someone that's coming that's the hon
honest truth that I can tell you but
before I leave boss bouncy offers a
little tip he tells me when scammers get
paid they like to celebrate have a few
[Music]
drinks hi good evening
you work
here the clubs and pool halls of arra
Ghana's Capital do you mind if I just go
up the stairs and see and then I come
down could be the perfect places to hear
things that shouldn't be
[Music]
heard okay here's our guy here's our guy
the guy that's going to stop and tell me
hi okay so you're the man to know here I
just going Street something just pass
you I know and I practically stopped you
after a bit of hustle I finally meet a
guy who says he can help I'll call one
of the guys awesome then we I'll text
you later in the night I get a message
telling me to go to a certain address
and to talk to the men playing
pool
hi hi so I know you don't want me to
call you by your real name so what
should we call you you can call me Odo
Odo and what does that mean it means
love love yeah so um you know why we're
here yeah yeah can you tell me a little
bit what you do I do the romance come
here
so how many women have you scammed more
than 22
men I've scam people from the states
people from Canada people from Germany
Poland Singapore finally I found a
[Music]
scammer what was your first fake name
Morris Jackson Morris Jackson yeah I
started way back um let me see in the
year
2008 I'm in a Ghana one of the
epicenters of romance scamming this man
Odo tells me he was introduced to
scamming by a friend and instantly saw
success I was talking to white woman she
was from um Canada I wasn't using my I
was using one model pretending it was
you yeah he's a very handsome guy any
woman that will see that guys picture
will fall in love with him the story Odo
fake is a favorite of romance
scammers work sent him to Ghana but
since no one took American Express here
he couldn't buy anything and needed cash
to be like how much do you need the
moment she commits by sending money for
the first time that means she's a very
good client client that's what they call
victims and so the first time you ever
received money was $300 from that
Canadian yeah and how much money do you
think you've made from this more than
$30,000 out of that wow yeah I was Shing
about five CLI at the same time it's all
like a script so I just copy and paste
to them these are scripts they scripts
yeah buy you buy them yeah I buy them
these scripts are almost like Choose
Your Own Adventure books except the
scammer chooses your adventure the
Romantic plot you'll follow based on the
answers you give and the type of person
he thinks you are I wanted a person to
travel with he he loved doing that he
wanted to show me the world he was going
to be leaving for about a months to go
to to the Far East to move hardwood
trees from Malaysia to India normally
when we start I just have to pretend I
see I'm from the state but I will move
in the next two three weeks to West
Africa it will be
like um that would be um you have to
yeah are you okay talking with people
coming in he's taking a risk speaking
with me the wrong person listening could
mean
trouble got a little nervous because
there are people looking I could see
your eyes you were nervous about who got
in and what they're listening yeah those
two guys that enter that I don't
know I'm putting so much R into what I'm
doing I have a boss he's a very rich
person he has a lot of boys working for
him really and what do you pay him a
percentage of what you make the boys go
online find clients when they get to
know we have good clients we push it to
him and then he
recover W this is news to me I'd assume
romance scammers worked as lone wolves
but he tells me it's more like a pack
with an experienced boss who knows how
to go in for the kill he's like a
finisher he's the person that finishes
it's the finisher who often writes the
scripts and takes over the transaction
once they're victim is ready to pay only
a small percentage goes to Frontline
scammers like Odo do you think I could
meet a finisher they would't why they
won't they will never do what I'm doing
so you wouldn't be able to talk to your
boss The Finisher about me right because
that would put you in danger
[Music]
yeah
[Applause]
okay so this person is still in the game
he's still scamming he's still in the
game I'm driving with a local journalist
who's been reporting on the scams for
years he's putting me in touch with a
scammer he knows in Kumasi about 150 mi
from Acra he says the dangers Odo
mentioned are real that's why he doesn't
want his identity revealed talk about
scamming in Ghana it's it's huge so any
attempt by anyone to want to you know
unravel anything get insight you could
be putting your life at
risk tell me more about the person we
meeting right so um he goes by the name
of the
Punisher and The Punisher The Punisher
he has this one other person you know he
works with he told me that there's a
place that actually went out um whenever
they have to have a video with a client
you know he's quite Secret in his
dealings they get worried trying to
protect their
business
I have no idea what to expect as I walk
up the stairs of this upscale apartment
building but instead of the Armed men
and pat down that I'm used to I'm
invited into a living room sweetheart I
can't see you oh there you are oh
where it looks like a romance scam is in
full swing so beautiful thank
[Music]
you he's going to fix
it on 60 minutes ago are you calling
somebody what if they
answer
hey
s I'm in Ghana watching two romance
scammers at work he calls himself The
Punisher and she is Miami
Queen I missed you and to my surprise
they're scamming men not
women how long has it been baby been the
while right I know but I told you I had
problems with my phone
H I understand I still love you
sweetheart let me go and take a shower
okay I'll call you when I'm done yeah
don't go anywhere just wait for
me
I so what just happened here you were
started to call somebody right and then
when he accepts if it's a video you pass
it on to her yeah when you're
communicating he thinks he's
communicating the whole time with her
but he's communicating with you and then
you're just mine is just to look
beautiful and make him feel sweet how
much I love
him most of romance scamming is
messaging just typing but they've rented
the space tonight for these occasional
video calls hoping to satisfy their
clients how many people do you guys know
that are scammers a whole lot of people
we have we have friends comers like
dozens hundreds
all your friends are doing it yeah I
have friends who are rich very rich
they've built houses big big cars
everybody's making money wiring money
gift cards or straight up cash are
preferred but payment in Bitcoin is also
becoming popular I'm a female I'm using
the profile of a female so you're
pretending to be a woman and scam I'm
pretending to be a
woman it's easier to get money from men
he says and there's simply more men
using online dating
[Music]
sites and yet back in the States far
fewer men than women report being
victims and this person you're talking
to Michael has no idea that you're
actually a man in Ghana
yes I started falling
love not for intercourse or whatever it
is but you know I I felt for him right
Michael is a kind hearted I think
Michael has been too good to me how much
money has Michael sent you so far more
than thank more than $10,000 for what
what do you say R apartment school fees
Michel knows I'm School here in GH wow
okay so I do this are you actually
calling him yes where is he Virginia
oh so Michael is not online oh okay no
dice but had Michael picked up he would
have seen this video recording of a
young woman this video will play when
you answer a call but if you talk it
doesn't match she's not talking you see
she's
typing oh my god wow so you have the
video and then you're just typing yes
where did you get this video you buy it
online oh you buy it yeah like scripts
these videos are part of a scammer's
professional toolkit an underground
industry unto
[Music]
itself
hi hi Honey
hi I love
you I
miss I keep watching them through the
night but no money has come in not even
from Michael
so they say it's time to take it to the
next
level this com is not really
moving if you're not adding black magic
this what I do I print a picture of
Michael and Michael's name and present
it to the priest the priest will use the
picture to tune Michael's mind that
whatever I ask Michael Michael has to
provide it for
me black mag
The Punisher will take us to the woman
who will put a love spell on
Michael one that will fill his heart and
empty his
[Music]
wallet
they call her Nana a title of high
respect in the local
language she plays a vital role in a
homegrown black magic infused scamming
culture called
sakua it links traditional West African
rituals and blessings to the god-given
fortunes of cyber fraud the kind aimed
at foreigners in far off lands
virgia scammers like The Punisher are
often called Saka boys and today he
really needs her powers to
work
for
[Music]
so you think that now that you've met
with the priest you're going to receive
the money exactly I'm going to receive
the money mhm now l than um 2 weeks how
much money have you made you think from
scamming more than $ 202k more than that
the black magic no it works perfectly
[Music]
yeah 20 grand is a lot of money
especially in
Ghana but it's Pocket Change compared to
what some of the bigger operators are
raking in
that's who I'm still trying to find one
of the alpha mes of the scamming World a
figure known as The
Finisher I think this is
it yeah so how a lot of these romance
cams are now being done by sort of
larger criminal networks and one of the
leaders of one of these groups has
agreed to meet us
the groundwork for this meeting started
back a week ago my local producer had
been digging and connected with a man
named pussycat who claimed to be a
finisher we first met him without
cameras on a rooftop in a c he said
little I could tell he was kidding
I left dubus that we would hear from him
again but to my surprise yesterday he
called and gave us this address up the
coast hi I'm the journalist you said I
could come and meet you with your
approve
you're supposed to prove to somebody
that we are American okay so you need a
document a driver license uh transport
kuu here is is the best for me to get
anything I
want oh wow does she actually exist the
real person no she doesn't
exist to my right is kiriku the master
of Forge
documents if a client wants proof of
anything he's the man to go to
it's a girl with a goat I need to put
that sheese in Singapore with a goat to
his right is Prince he's the hunter
you're the first person in this you
start looking on different dating sites
yeah his talent choosing the right bait
while casting the whitest net cuz
there's a lot of different fish in the
sea I will give you a photo based on how
I see you if I see that you are
intelligent I'll find a very smart photo
to give you then comes the impersonator
he goes by the name Shadow I make the
calls sort of like the actor I guess
exactly yeah hey hi James how are you
that's his voice when he scams men all
right honey
bye and finally the guy who brought me
here
pussycat and what is yours then I'm the
final Striker like the finisher The
Finisher at last The Finisher you start
the goal of it all which is getting the
money because I'm I'm enlightened more
on and the kind of format I should be
giving them format he says it's another
word for script initially we used to
copy and paste them right but it could
be that the person has received the same
format from somebody right I'm going to
write to so that it's going to differ so
you don't need to copy and paste you
have it all in your head I have them
here it's his long experience mining the
psyche of clients that gives the
finisher the insights to write these
fake scenarios to know his ideology to
know how mature he is and what I can do
to let him understand that I'm real
whether you call them scripts or formats
they're the Beating Heart of the scams
multi-million dollar industry as soon as
you read the format whatever you have in
your account you're going to pull it out
you're that convincing sure even you if
we want to scam you we can do that you
think so yeah you know sometimes we can
talk to you for about one year without
not asking you with d we can even
sending your money you can be sending
your money can be buying your gifts food
St buy gold and send it to you so that
will make you it's
okay that's okay what do you mean you
don't want him to say more
yes pussycat immediately Cuts things off
but I get it small gifts might lure me
to reciprocate with bigger gifts and
someday maybe a cash loan this is how we
do it though they aren't willing to give
out their formats they let me listen in
on a call all in Texas yeah and it's a
man as well yeah yes it's another male
victim how old do it I'm quickly
realizing that targeting men is actually
quite common here even though we hear
almost exclusively about female victims
you mostly hunt for men and we also have
some Hunters who are hunting for women
they're all telling me the same thing
not only do men have more money they're
much easier to
full
hello yeah can you hear
me hey hi buny how are
you how are you doing why can I see H I
have a little problem with my
camera that sucks yeah sorry
okay hey what's up I miss you when are
you coming up okay I'm going to be up in
like half an
hour in a half hour you're coming up
take you an hour and a half to get
here asking you when are you coming
up when do you want me to come there a
month
ago okay I know but you know because of
the Corona virus oh you have the virus
now I no no no no no I don't have the
virus personally but it's in here now
Africa looks like someone has gone off
script
[Music]
hello when do you want me to come there
a month
ago okay I know but you know because of
the Corona virus it's in here in
Africa that's enough
St I'm with a den of romance scammers in
Ghana they're working together to scam a
man in Texas hello but because they're
juggling dozens of active clients they
briefly lose track of the script
hello can you hear
me
hello
I would like to come over like this
weekend but I don't have enough gas in
my car and I had to use that little box
she sent me to get some little
medications all right okay bye for now
bye love
you
I still don't understand how they
explain their strange accents but maybe
they're right men looking for love are
just easier to
fool so in this format it's an American
Girl willing to go see this person and
is waiting for you and he sending you
money to go and see him yeah and what's
his name his first name is James how
much money has James sent 00 bucks $100
$100 gas for gas it's a new client and
what does James think you look like
beautiful woman I've been sending him
videos to so it's not difficult to find
photos and videos it is difficult
because you may not know where to get
them and we are not going to tell you
the sit you can get them because that
would ruin your business that is my
strength but I cannot do the graphic
works but kuu here is very good if you
could have a job as an actual graphic
designer professional graphic designer
would you rather do that yeah that's
what I want to do but I have no job I
have nothing I have a kid I have a
family so working with a team I get
enough to take care of my
family volume expertise efficiency sure
they make mistakes hello baby can you
hear me but with their strength and
numbers they can regroup readjust and
scale up their romantic Pursuits over
and over and over
again after he confess
I felt so stupid I had been a former Air
Force intelligence officer I had been a
senior bank manager I'd had legal
training I was running a
company people say don't send money to a
stranger well he wasn't a Stranger by
that point this guy knew more about me
than probably any man had ever known he
texted me back one day and said I'm a
poor black man from
Africa
my whole world
just fell
apart completely
shattered hi Ben hi Ben hi how's it
going it's great how are you I'm doing
well back in the States I again meet up
with Susan she wants me to witness
something she's been eager to do for
quite some time sounds like you've run
into some questionable uh lovers she's
Enlisted the help of Ben Taylor a scam
Buster who exposes many of their tricks
on his popular YouTube channel today
we're going to talk about a scam that
happens to you when you're online
looking for someone to have a good time
with he's part of a growing number of
cyber Vigilantes disrupting the work of
scammers some have been able to freeze
assets shut down their bank accounts
even hack into their
computers so tell me a little bit about
these these folks that have reached out
to you how did it begin I uh signed up
on Facebook dating I met Damian after
two weeks of chatting he asked uh for
$15,000 to help him get home wow in fact
when I interviewed Susan before I left
for Ghana she told me that nearly every
man she met online after Daman was also
a scammer I met Ryan and then I met Joe
and Joe and Kenny played their game very
well it's guy after guy after guy after
guy probably
90% of them are fake frustrated and fed
up she decided to fight back so You'
talk to some of these gentlemen on the
phone is that right one calls me every
morning and every evening he thinks I'm
going to go get $8,000 out of my bank
and take it to the Bitcoin location well
are you going to do it I'm going to
pretend to do it okay the scammer named
Paul says he's working on an oil rig in
the Gulf of Mexico I'm doing some
reverse image searches to see if I can
find this guy anywhere I haven't found
anything
yet oh hold on I think I've just found
something first thing that pops up is a
David Hoffman who's a lifting supervisor
so you think the real guy is called
David Hoffman and that this guy is using
that photo I'm thinking that there's a
guy in Northern Ireland who has no idea
that somebody else is using his picture
I would agree okay so maybe we can try
to find out who this guy is and where
he's from okay okay so I'm just off work
he wants to talk on the phone yeah all
right one
second I can't wait to hear this guy's
voice okay all right here we
go hello
honey honey are you
there hello baby are you doing oh I'm
better now I'm talking to
you listen I'm getting ready ready to
head to the bank okay you know what you
need to do right I do and honey I forgot
why why did you need the money I forgot
yeah so I told you about the equipment
for by custom so I I have to pay the
clearance for that's why right right
yeah so why you see me what are you
going to do well my first reaction will
be to run up and give you a big hug and
kiss yeah I love
honey can you hold just a
second I think you're muted we might be
able to see exactly where he is but we
need him to click on a
link what if we tell him that you're
withdrawing the money right now and
you're on your way to the Bitcoin
machine we could probably send them the
link to a location like a gas station or
something where the Bitcoin machine is
and we can say is this the place I need
to go to deposit the money and if he
clicks on it then I might have some
information to give you
okay okay okay
s all right now we all wait and pray
that he's dumb enough to click on the
link oh my
God I'm sort of nervous are you yeah
feel like he's going to jump right out
of it and grab
us all right I just got a
clip
let's go ahead and tell him that you are
getting the money now okay s all right
now we all wait and pray that he's dumb
enough to click on the
[Music]
link I'm sort of nervous are you yeah
right all right I just got a click
they clicked it both the FBI and the
Secret Service can take on
investigations but rarely can they bring
Justice to American victims that's why
so many are turning to people like Ben
not only to search for their money but
with a craving to give these scammers a
dose of their own
medicine I've got all the information
right here are you ready yes the scammer
named Paul says he's working on an oil
rig in the Gulf of Mexico the time zone
in his phone is putting him in Acra
Ghana wow aquar Ghana where the heck is
that in West Africa in Ghana according
to a 2018 research paper only Nigeria
tops Ghana in housing the IP addresses
of romance scammers but since Ghana is
only a seventh of Nigeria's population
one country is clearly punching above
its weight all right so I'm getting
ready now to block him because we're
done with him right all we had was Paul
City not his real name or address or
anything that might lead to an actual
bust but still Susan is clearly enjoying
Ben's help oh it's Lucas oh it's Lucas
okay we'll talk to Lucas hi honey hey
beautiful how are
you I'm good I just wanted to talk to
you a lots of criminals lie and steal
but a romance scammer con is more
intimate I love you honey I love you too
sweetie their payday depends on gaining
the trust and affection of another human
being I'll be waiting for you online I
wonder if that leaves them more
conflicted I I love Michael he's been so
kind to me you know since I met him I
did believe the Punisher when he told me
he'd fallen in love with his victim do
you think he'd be so sad if he found out
that you were a man yeah everybody will
feel sad if it happens to him or her you
know he might go through a lot to forget
this you know maybe he might commit a
suicide or
something he didn't receive 20,000 from
Michael but they're still in an online
relationship I just have to say this to
be able to be to be free it's something
that I did that pains me so much anytime
I think about it I regret him doing it
for Odo seeing one of his victims
evicted from her home actually made him
leave the game I took $3,000 that she's
using in pain was a whole lot that I li
to her it's a very sad thing it's a very
St thing you have glasses on and we
can't see very well but I can um you're
getting emotional talking about this
yeah yeah yeah it CS me so much me
remembering it it CS me so much but my
Miami Queen sees no reason to feel
remorse quite people came to Africa when
it was like gold Co made us slaves and
killed a whole lot of people it's a
justification I've heard before so we
feel like you guys owe us a lot scams as
reparations we need to survive Africa
need to survive at the expense of other
people suffering
yes I wonder if you know how much harm
you're actually inflicting on someone in
our case we interviewed mostly women and
now it's difficult for them to find
other people to trust other people some
of people lost millions of dollars I
know all this kind of stories it happens
it's not easy sleeping without food so
it's easier to sleep with a guilty
conscience than it is with an empty
stomach yeah but you know you know
everybody is finding able to
survive
you have to come here sometimes and help
somebody get some fish you go out and
sell it to survive else you won't eat
the whole day before I left Ghana
pussycat wanted to show me a fishing
Village not far from where he grew
up so what's the percentage of people if
they're born in a community like this
that they're able to get out of poverty
H it's very very very very minute I mean
most of them are born here they live
here and they die here
because there's no
hope when I come here I see young girls
and I've been telling them they should
study hard how do they buy those books
so sometimes we come and share books for
them these are potential national
[Laughter]
leaders yeah so he want to be a
footballer a footballer what
playd Cristiano Ronaldo Cristiano
Ronaldo that's a good choice Portuguese
he want to be a banker he wants to be a
banker yes he want to do a banker no one
grows up wanting to become a romance cam
it's a decision made out of desperation
okay mechanical engineer mechanical
engineer yeah so you see they have
dreams but I also understand that people
do what they have to do to survive and
to provide for their
families
that urge is
universal maybe as universal as the
search for love
[Music]
itself